we begin with tough times ahead during
the pandemic as the cdc
projects 85 000 more americans could die
in just the next three weeks this comes
as january already marks the deadliest
month on record
we're also getting a troubling new
visualization of the toll of the
pandemic
disaster relief surgeon dr arghavan
solis has spent the last two months
working in a phoenix icu
she tweeted this photo writing quote
here are the folks
i've cared for with kovit who have died
big stack
and survived little stack in the last
two months
you can see the stack of papers for
patients she's lost to the virus
is nearly double the one for those who
survived we spoke with dr
saulis about why she shared that picture
each card represents a person and i
think that
when we see statistics like 3 000 people
have died or 4 000 people have died
um honestly i think at this point people
are pretty numb to that
and i thought it might be helpful for
people to see what happens
when patients are in the icu and the
vast majority of them
at least the ones who make it onto a
ventilator don't end up surviving
dr salas says she hopes the photo helps
convince americans to get vaccinated
against the coronavirus the governor of
texas has agreed to help a young
teenager who made a
desperate plea after his mother fell
seriously ill
from the coronavirus in a letter to the
governor that's greg abbott
emilian sosa explained that his mother
is the only immediate family he has
left and she's quote hanging on for dear
life
the 14 year old then asked for help to
get her ecmo therapy which is often seen
as a treatment of last resort for
seriously and severely ill covered
patients
maria virial spoke with emilian
yesterday maria good morning to you
simple question how's he doing well
emilian
is definitely a fighter and he is doing
everything he can right now this kid is
amazing his birthday is actually next
week and he said all he wants as a gift
is to get access to treatment for his
mother
every day he plays a violin concert for
her
on a video chat while she is lying in
bed in a hospital
fighting for her life
[Music]
erica calderon was admitted to the
hospital in south texas
just after new year's her
fourteen-year-old son emilian sosa
helped carry her to the ambulance she's
been intubated for a week
i first dating christ because i was like
in a panic it said like
we have to get her down immediately
doctors say calderon's lungs have been
destroyed by covid
limiting her treatment options but after
researching the family found
ecmo extracorporeal membrane oxygenation
it's a form of life support that uses a
special machine to add oxygen to the
blood
giving the lungs time to heal but that
machine isn't available at any hospital
near him in the rio grande valley
meaning emilian's mom a housekeeper
living on a limited budget
would need thousands of dollars to be
transported to another hospital
hundreds of miles away and so this has
been difficult i would imagine you're
having to deal with some grown-up stuff
we need to get the help as much as
possible so that's why i set up that
goal for me
determined to fight for his mom emilian
set up a fundraising effort to try and
pay for a helicopter
to transport her he also wrote a letter
to texas governor greg abbott
asking for help elizabeth guerrero is
his high school counselor
when you hear emilian saying
okay i'm writing the governor you know
i've got to figure this out i mean this
is a 14 year old boy
did any part of you say oh it may not go
the way you want
it to yes because you know we
we live in a world where horrible things
happen we
have seen it time and time again where
people don't make it people don't
respond
within 24 hours sosa raised more than
30 thousand dollars his plea for help
making its way to the lone star state
capitol
governor abbott tweeting wednesday night
he spoke with emilian
and the equipment his mother needs was
located
adding she should be in good medical
care
proof that sometimes even the smallest
voices
get heard regardless of the outcome it's
been proven that he's not alone in this
world
a team of medical professionals
evaluated miss calderon last night and
they do believe that she is strong
enough to be transported as of right now
we understand that will happen
later today she will be taken to houston
to herman memorial
where she will get that specialized
treatment
an extraordinary story maria thank you
and what an extraordinary 14 year old
emilian is thank you